[Music]
eminem brought the energy with a special
rendition of his hit song lose yourself
during his epic halftime performance at
super bowl 56 in los angeles
the rapper who rocked a black hoodie
gray t-shirt and jordan 3's even got
some help on the drums from anderson
pack
[Music]
both artists took the stage as part of a
star-studded ensemble featuring
performances from dr dre snoop dogg mary
j blige 50 cent and kendrick lamar
in the stands supporting her dad was
eminem's 26 year old daughter haley who
shared this snapshot from above the
field captioning a quote here for the
halftime show staying for stafford
shouting out the los angeles rams
quarterback matthew stafford
[Music]
eminem capped off his section of the
halftime show by taking a knee which
appears to show a sign of solidarity
with nfl players who have used the
gesture as a sign of protest most
famously by colin kaepernick this comes
after reports surfaced that the nfl had
told eminem not to kneel which a
spokesperson for the organization tells
e.t is not true saying quote we watched
every rehearsal this week and that
element was included adding quote
players and personnel members could have
taken a knee today so there would have
been no reason to tell a performer he or
she could not for whatever reason
this year's super bowl marked the first
time that hip-hop took center stage
during halftime and the creative genius
behind the show was la's own dr dre
ahead of their performance eminem sat
down with shui on sway in the morning
and opened up about the super producer's
vision for this history-making moment
i was trying to envision what dre might
do
okay you know like
i was thinking like yeah that's dope all
of us are gonna rap together right
and that kind of thing but i didn't
expect it to be like the production to
be like this et spoke with super bowl
halftime show executive producer jesse
collins backstage about dre's impact on
the artists who performed in the music
industry at large it is everyone is in
tears because
you know that
you know dre
changed music
go back to nwa he made the world look at
the west coast and what they were saying
and then he has continued to change it
over and over again eminem 50 cent it
goes on and on kendrick snoop it's like
he keeps keeps changing music changing
music for the world
[Music]
you